remember when the molar report came out
and I reminded you that there are more
than a dozen matters that were referred
out by molar to other prosecutors and
investigators that was all true but the
total number of investigations into
Trump is actually reaching sort of a
mind-boggling level at this point the
New York Times had a great article about
it yesterday and the total number of
investigations is now 29 huh it's ten
federal criminal investigations eight
state and local investigations and
eleven congressional investigation so
let's take a look at some of these
starting with the federal criminal Trump
investigations you've got the Southern
District of New York looking at Trump's
inauguration 'el Committee inaugural
committee donations in spending you have
the Eastern District of New York looking
at the inaugurals ties to the Middle
East
you have the Justice Department looking
at the business and politics dealings of
a top fundraiser for the Trump campaign
you have the southern district looking
into the role of Trump and others in
hush money payments Trump's lawyers
offering a pardon to Cohen and inflated
insurance claims
you've got the United States attorney's
office in DC that is still prosecuting
Roger stone you have the southern
district looking at lobbying violations
by manna fort recruited firms you still
have a pending criminal case against the
man afford associate and you also have a
manna fort connected Bank officer who
was reportedly seeking a Trump
administration job that is being
investigated we then have the state and
local investigations the New York
Department of Financial Services is
looking at the Trump organizations
insurance practices that's the best
you've got the New Jersey Attorney
General looking at inaugural
contributions you have the DC Attorney
General looking at the role of Donald
Trump's kids in business in the
inauguration and then there's also a
Manhattan district attorney case against
Paul Manafort at the state level the New
York Attorney General is looking into
the misuse of charitable assets and
campaign finance violations by Trump's
charity at the Trump organizations
inflation of financial assets and at
family tax schemes by the Trump family
and New York City is also looking at
Donald Trump and his family potentially
under paying their taxes and then lastly
if there are congressional
investigations which in and of
themselves are not criminal but if and
when people start lying sort of like the
way Don jr. did to the Senate
Intelligence Committee these can become
criminal very quickly the list there
includes the House Intelligence
Committee looking at foreign influence
on Trump the House Oversight Committee
looking at Trump's role in concealing
hush money payments the House Judiciary
Committee looking at the Trump
administration's possible obstruction of
justice including Trump himself House
Oversight looking at both abuse of the
security clearance process and Trump's
lies about his net worth in addition to
private messaging by White House
officials that includes both email and I
believe possibly whatsapp House Ways and
Means as we've talked about before
looking at Donald Trump's tax returns
and obtaining those and and what may
those may reveal multiple committees
looking at Donald Trump's communications
with Vladimir Putin the House
Intelligence Committee looking at
money-laundering the Senate intelligence
committees still looking at Russian
interference and House Oversight looking
at a proposed nuclear venture in Saudi
Arabia so 29 different investigations
going on right now if you thought it was
over with molars report it wasn't and
this is evidence of that but the the
really important remaining question is
number one okay well so the the micro
question is are there sealed indictments
in any of these investigations we don't
know there's been speculation about
sealed indictments from the molar probe
probe that was proven I believe to have
been wrong could there be sealed
indictments here maybe could there be
upcoming indictments that's also
possible but the bigger question is is
he gonna get away with everything and I
mean tell me I'm wrong but I believe
that Donald Trump probably will get away
with all of it and the only possible
consequence would be getting voted out
in November of 2020 if we all do the
right thing and go out and vote so 29
investigations I anticipate zero
consequences let's just remove the guy
in November
20 and be done with it